hi there
day one
actually it's day two of my
link challenge uh in korean
uh day two i say because yesterday i was
preparing material i'm gonna go through
a little bit of the resources that i'm
gathering a couple of comments first
a starting point i'm going to list here
or put in the description box a link to
a
video interview that i did in korean so
you have a sense of where i'm starting
from
and we'll see if i can achieve any
improvement over the next three months
uh the second thing is that i saw on
facebook that four very well-respected
polyglots um
alex rawlings luca i can't remember the
others they did this one hour
to learn romanian and they spoke
remarkably good romanian after one hour
here i am i've been at korea for
you know i don't know four five six
years off and on a few months here a few
months there i'm not satisfied with my
level in korean i still find it
difficult to understand certainly the
podcast i listen to i don't fully
understand them some parts i understand
better than others
so here are these people in one hour
they can say stuff in romania
and wonderful and they're very good
polyglots
the point is that it's not difficult to
learn to say something in a short period
of time whether it be an hour a week two
weeks a month however
to achieve fluency which is always
eventually my goal
actually takes a long time and to get
where you understand well where you can
express yourself freely takes a long
time or maybe i'm just stupid and some
languages are more difficult than others
i'm finding korean difficult even though
i have a lot of advantages i speak
chinese i speak japanese
i'm an experienced language learner
at any rate
my challenge my goal is to conquer
korean so you can see where i'm starting
from and we'll see where i am and i'm
going to post a video every day because
arvid who follows my uh youtube channel
said why don't you do that you did it
the last time i wasn't planning to but i
will now very quickly on the subject of
resources and i can get into that again
and i'm also happy to hear from other
people
but
what i did yesterday because i'm in
japan i bought this book which is korean
kbs drama and it has audio and text
however i had hannah who very kindly
agreed to transcribe it so that i can
handle it in link i loaded up the audio
so i'm going to be doing kbs drama i've
kind of dabbled in it found it difficult
but i'm gonna
my intention is to read everything and
to get all the vocabulary that's in all
of these nine short drama sessions
uh
there was another one i may get to
which is this uh you know hyojun hyojung
param like
what you call standard pronunciation may
or may not get to it if i had if i'm
going to do this on link i'm going to
have to ask hannah to transcribe it
again which is not fair
then i had earlier bought because my
first korean book was put out by ross
king at ubc it's called continuing
korean not quite the first i also
started way back when with colloquial
korean
but i i was able to find on the internet
a digital version of advanced korean
and continuing korean
and so i have loaded them
into link and i've started doing them on
link so that i can save the words and
phrases and i'm really enjoying by the
way doing the dictation flash cards
multiple choice the way they show up
randomly now so it's not so boring it's
not just flashcards and in subsequent
videos i'll go into how i do all of that
so i am looking for
resources that i can bring in
and study at link i've got a bunch of
podcasts kim yo-ha and shisha tong that
have been transcribed so that's going to
keep me busy
and when i spoke to ross king at ubc the
other day he told me that there is a
website ubc korean 410
and there's a bunch of stuff there
modern korean literature with all kinds
of resources so i'm also uploading those
into links so yesterday and over the you
know today and so forth i'm kind of
gathering all the resources
so that i will have plenty of stuff and
plenty of variety because variety is the
spice of life and by the way this
morning i got up early to play golf and
i twittered about that tweeted about
that but now uh it's time to get at my
korean so this is my first it's a little
bit longer
i will typically be putting up much
shorter videos hopefully on a daily
basis so and i hope that you are
committing to your challenge in whatever
language
you are going to do and remember to
submit your questions and if your
question is selected you may have a
chance
whether you want you know a chance that
we can have a chance to have a 15 minute
conversation in a language that you are
interested in and that i happen to speak
okay then thank you bye for now
you